how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder and today we have some very
interesting DC news it appears as if we
may actually get some kind of version of
the Snyder cut of the Justice League now
I know that many people have said that
in the past but just recently this month
and in the past couple of days many
people including some big names and
media outlets are stating that it could
happen and it could happen pretty soon
and possibly on HBO max the hype is so
big right now that Jason Momoa himself
took to Instagram in his story to say
release the Snyder cut we're just
sitting around doing nothing
release the Snyder cut am i right you
know I mean like what are we waiting for
some goodies in there I'm just gonna go
ahead and put it out there so hopefully
you know generally what out there comes
true let's hope it does release so I'll
go over these reports and this video
that claimed that we could be getting
the Snyder cut soon and I'll speak very
transparently and plainly because I know
that this is a sensitive subject to some
people if you're new to my channel be
sure to subscribe we cover DC and Marvel
news and for this week's giveaway I'm
giving away a Captain America Avengers
in-game Funko pop all you have to do is
subscribe like the video and leave a
comment down below so I'll explain all
of the hype about us possibly getting
the Snyder cut it all happened about a
month ago
earlier in the month heroic Hollywood
reported that Zack Snyder screened a
version of his Justice League cut for
Warner Brothers fandom wire also
reported this as well that Warner
Brothers met with Snyder about his
Justice League cut and in their report
they said that it would cost about 20
million to finish that would include new
filming now since then a lot of known
names that are insiders that get a lot
of inside information are saying that
yes there is actually a possibility that
it is coming Peters kureta the founder
and owner of slash film previously
reported along with a couple of other
companies that we were not going to get
the Snyder cut but just yesterday he
tweeted saying I was wrong it's
happening and then grace Randolph
from beyond the trailer even tweeted
saying because the news is all over town
that the deal is closing as we speak
expect an official announcement very
soon and the story could leak via a
trade even sooner
she then replied to a tweet of somebody
asking when to expect a video on it and
she said I will make a video as soon as
there's an official announcement I
really feel Zack Snyder should get to
reveal but if a big outlet reports the
story all bets are off and I will cover
two and then we have other websites like
DC EU mythic and comicbook.com covering
the story as well both saying that it
could be coming more on that in a bit
but to top it all off Zack Snyder
announced that he's going to be doing a
Man of Steel watch party and what's
really interesting about this is the
timing of it all and the fact that it's
not doing anything specifically such as
celebrating an anniversary or promoting
an upcoming film Snyder said that it's
simply to uplift people's spirits
many people think that there could be
some sort of an announcement when he
does this watch party for Man of Steel
perhaps after the film was done and
what's even more interesting is that the
studio and reps for Warner Brothers are
remaining quiet typically as seen in the
past they would speak up and say no you
are not ever getting a Snyder cut
version of the Justice League they would
say that it's not happening but now when
reporters reach out to the studio they
all of a sudden have no comment and this
is something else that gives fans hope
the fact that they're not commenting
means that they could be planning to
release it soon now reports from
comicbook.com
and DC you mythic comm say that it could
be released via HBO max now as most of
us know the Snyder cut isn't really
fully complete much of the movie had
been shot but the visual effects on the
movie were not completed to theatrical
quality and again according to reports
it would cost twenty million to finish
in which Warner Brothers is not
interested however that doesn't mean
that they can't just release the cut as
is there's an opportunity for them to
release it in theaters as they start to
open back up the studio is already re
releasing the Dark Knight trilogy in
theaters overseas so they could choose
the show the Snyder cut in theaters as
they open back up after it goes to
theaters it could then go to HBO max
which we have reports of as well
ECE you mythic says that it could go to
HBO max as a film or as a series a
series would simply be the Snyder cut
film chopped up in two different
episodes but HBO max right now is kind
of facing a hard time with their fans
every time that HBO puts out a promotion
for HBO max it's bombarded with hashtag
released the Snyder cut comments so the
studio could see this as a way to make
everybody happy and also produce good
content at the same time of course
nothing is for sure but it does seem
like right now more than ever the
chances of getting a Snyder cut of the
Justice League is higher than it's ever
been before the studio is being quiet
about it not giving any comments
insiders are saying that it is coming
and Snyder apparently met with Warner
Brothers so hopefully for all of those
fans who have been waiting for the
Snyder cut to be released hopefully
we'll have something soon but what do
you think do you think we're going to
get it or do you think we're never going
to get it let me know what you think in
the comments down below and again for DC
and Marvel news be sure to subscribe to
my channel so you don't miss out on
anything
be sure to hit the like button and you
can follow me on Twitter for live
updates as always thank you all so much
for watching
woof woof